in other videos we talked about how 10
to 15,000 years ago you have the
emergence of Agriculture primarily
around river valleys and it's no
surprise that agriculture first came
about around river valleys because the
rivers would flood making the soy the
soil around them fertile it would
provide fresh water for crops and for
the people who would live near them
later on the rivers could be useful for
transporting things like crops and so
it's not surprising that our first
significant civilizations also emerged
where the first agriculture emerged and
our first civilizations will see in
ancient Egypt along the Nile we will see
it in the Indus Valley along the Indus
River we'll see it in China along the
yellow and Yangtze rivers and we'll also
see it in Mesopotamia along the Tigris
and Euphrates rivers and what we're
going to focus on in this video
in particular is Mesopotamia now the
word Mesopotamia literally comes from
Mae sews between and Potter most I'm
probably not pronouncing it right rivers
so the area between rivers is literally
what Mesopotamia is referring to and
it's Mae it's primarily modern-day Iraq
now the reason why this is particularly
interesting and it's called the cradle
of civilization is not only is it one of
or perhaps the first place that
agriculture developed it was at the the
crossroads of many other early
civilizations notice it's right in
between the Indus Valley Civilisation
here yeah and then the ancient Egyptian
and other civilizations that were
emerging in the area and so it's not
surprising that this was a geography
that had significant development in
terms of Technology in terms of
architecture in terms of religion in
terms of writing and the first
civilization we believe that emerged in
Mesopotamia are the Sumerians Sumerians
and Sumire & Sumerians it's most
associated with this region right over
here of let me circle it this region
right over here
of southern Mesopotamia and we currently
think that this civilization started to
emerge around 4000 BCE you can see it on
this timeline here in orange and they
developed things as basic as the wheel
the first wheel that was ever discovered
was 3500 BCE in Sumeria they are famous
for their architectural structures this
is a picture here of a ziggurat which is
at the center of many of these Sumerian
and as we'll see Mesopotamian cities
this would have required an incredible
amount of labor to produce it at the top
of these they had temples to their gods
and their gods it was a Pollock they had
a polytheistic religion and their gods
take took human form also in in amongst
the Sumerians is where we think one of
the first written languages developed it
wasn't the first you also have the
Egyptian hieroglyphic so we think
written and written language emerged
amongst the Harappans and the Indus
Valley Civilisation and amongst the
Chinese but it was one of the first
languages this right over here is an
example of a cuneiform tablet this is a
cuneiform tablet written in the script
cuneiform developed by these ancient
Sumerians now when you talk about
Mesopotamia you'll talk about some areas
but we'll also talk about other
civilizations that emerge in particular
let me write them all down you have the
Sumerians you'll also hear something
called Akkadian and as we'll see
Akkadian is both a language and an
empire that will emerge in Mesopotamia
over the the roughly 3,000 years BCE the
two primary primary languages are
Akkadian which is considered a Semitic
language it's related to modern Semitic
languages like Arabic and Hebrew and the
reason why they're called Semitic is
because they're spoken or they're
purported to be spoken by the
descendants of Shem who was Noah's son
in the Hebrew Bible so you have the
language Akkadian which is Semitic and
then you have the other language which
is Sumerian and as we get into the third
millennium be
de the Sumerians start to have a lot of
interaction with Akkadian speaking
people and Akkadian speaking people are
initially associated primarily with
northern Mesopotamia and we believe the
first Empire true Empire perhaps the
first Empire in the world emerged from
Acadia and it was called the Akkadian
Empire and if we scroll down over here
we can see how the Akkadian Empire
spread we believe that the town of Akkad
which the Akkadian empires named for
some place in this region right over
here and the first significant ruler who
really spread that Empire was Sargon
often referred to as Sargon the great
and you can see you can see that that
would have been established around the
middle of the 23rd or actually the 24th
century BCE so around 2350 you have
Sargon establishing what might be the
first dynastic Empire in the world the
Akkadian Empire and he was able to take
control of both northern and southern
Mesopotamia so even the Sumerians were
under the control of the Acadians and as
we'll see over time you have a lot of
mixing between the Akkadian language the
Sumerian language Akkadian gets written
in the cuneiform script and starting it
around this period Sumerian starts to
die as a spoken language and Akkadian
really becomes dominant
now the Acadians rule for a little over
a hundred years and then you have
several other empires you can get
confusing the way I've structured this
timeline is this top line right over
here it's southern Mesopotamia and this
bottom line right over here is northern
Mesopotamia so this orange shows you
where the Sumerians were reigning some
people think that they might have been
the first Empire this bottom line here
you can see the Akkadian speakers but
they were fragmented until you have
Sargon the great establishing the
Akkadian Empire now you briefly you
briefly then have a short term neo
Sumerian Empire but the next significant
Empire that's often talked about when
associated with Mesopotamia is the
Babylonian Empire
so Babylon Babylonian Empire was
centered at Babylon
right over here and it really became a
significant Empire
under the ruler Hammurabi and Homer Ravi
is perhaps most known you can see how he
was able to spread the Empire the dark
the dark brown is what he had with his
empire when he took rule and the light
brown is what he was able to spread it
to so once again both north and south
and he's perhaps most famous for his
famous code of hammurabi which is
depicted here and it wasn't the first
written code but it was one of the
earliest and you could view it as almost
like a proto Constitution and it was
based on things that the Sumerians had
before but they've even influenced
things like biblical laws things that
come down to modern codes of law today
now after the Babylonians the other
significant Empire that would have
control over significant portions of
Mesopotamia is the Assyrian Empire and
the Assyrian Empire is named for their I
guess you could say their home base the
town of us or you can see it in this map
here when we showed the Akkadian Empire
and both the Babylonians and the
Assyrians were kadian speaking so at
this point now and as we get into the
later Syrian period we'll start to have
our make be a more significant language
another Semitic language but as you can
see here the Assyrian Empire at its peak
controlled much of the modern-day Middle
East now the Assyrian Empire would
eventually collapse in the seventh
century BCE and would be taken over by
the neo-babylonian empire and I have a
map of that right over here which also
controlled much of the modern Middle
East probably the most famous ruler of
the neo-babylonian empire was
Nebuchadnezzar the second from the
Hebrew Bible famous for taking the the
early Jewish people captive the famous
Babylonian captivity but eventually they
would be overthrown and they will be
overthrown in the 6th century BCE by the
Persians and Cyrus the Great and that
will actually be the end of the
Babylonian captivity according to
biblical accounts but the big picture is
that Mesopotamia is called the cradle of
civilization for
a good reason not only do we have these
technological and architectural
advancements their religion their
writing has influenced civilization
since for the last five six seven
thousand years I would say definitely
the last five thousand years and a lot
of these ideas that came out of
Mesopotamia like written codes of law
and the technologies and the and all the
rest follow with us today